Okay.
We were talking about the development of the Athenian Empire,
um,
changing from the original character of the Delian League.
I think we've gotten to the battle of you Rimma Don,
which is generally data to four 69,
the great victory at land and sea over the Persians and the
feeling that it generated certainly in some portions of the empire that the
threat from Persia was over.
And that created the problem of keeping the,
uh,
allies,
satisfied and willing to make the kind of contribution that had been necessary.
The,
it Samian certainly had no plan
of abandoning the league,
of abandoning their leadership,
of giving up their assaults on the Persians and all of that.
Uh,
so that if there was a falling away,
the Athenians would be wanting to do something about that.
Still another turning point in the character of the league,
a very important one I think occurred in the year four 65 when the island of say
sauce in the northern Aegean Sea rebelled.
And this time the quarrel was not about,
uh,
doing the duty that the members of the league had to do.
It was not about,
uh,
something that was an issue,
not wanting to take part of campaigns,
not wanting to make payments,
no,
nothing like that.
There was a quarrel between the Athenians and the Asians about some minds that
were worked on the land opposite,
say sauce,
gold and silver,
very rich,
uh,
precious metal sources for the ancient Greek world of which there were not many
located on Mt.
Penn GN on the mainland opposite say sauce.
Both states claimed those minds and it was a quarrel that was really just about
money.
Uh,
there was also a trading post up there that both sides claimed to have.
The Athenians had established a colony,
uh,
at a place on the strike.
I'm on river up in that region called and they are,
oh boy,
the nine roads,
uh,
which will lay there when the Athenians established it as a colony would be cold
and fearless.
Uh,
all of that led to an end.
The Ephesians didn't like that the Athenians were moving into their sphere of
influence and giving them trouble.
So they saw us as a consequence of all of these quarrels rebuilt.
And it was a very difficult siege that the Athenians had to employ face us as a
relatively big island,
that Asians are a pretty tough group to put down.
And the siege,
actually,
the war between Athens and face faces actually took something like two years,
which is quite a long stretch for any Greek combat and certainly had not been
typical of what the Athenians had been able to do against other rebellions.
When the,
uh,
Asians were finally forced to surrender,
the Athenians gave them the usual treatment too.
Rebellious states,
they made them take down their walls to give up their ships.
And of course the Athenians took control of the minds and placed and indemnity
on the Asians requiring that they should pay the costs of the war for Athens and
the imposed upon them thereafter,
the same kind of attribute that they imposed on what came in more and more to B
two B and we'll called subject states.
Well,
that wasn't the first time such a thing had happened to one of the members of
the league.
But what made it different was that the quarrel was not over.
Anything that had to do with the league,
it could easily be seen in certainly was a way in which the Athenians used the
forces and the funds of the League to achieve strictly Athenian advantages.
After all,
it was no way that the league benefited from having either Athens or face us
exploit those mines.
It was not an issue for the league at all.
And yet the Athenians had taken their position as leaders of the league to gain
that advantage.
And that's I think a very important turning point.
Uh,
we shall see that it was in the course of that siege of say sauce important
events were happening back in the mainland of Greece,
which would change the nature of things too.
But,
uh,
if we just think about the league for a moment,
I think decision rebellion is a critical moment and that is a good place for us
to look at.
The evaluation that the ancient writers made of this transition are two.
Two sources are a major source of course,
the acidities and then also dive doors of Sicily,
a deriving his opinions from contemporary writers to come up with descriptions
and explanations of why the league changed from what had been a free association
of states pursuing a common goal to what was legitimately called an empire.
Here is what Diet Doris says.
He says in general,
the Athenians were making great gains in power and no longer treated allies with
decency as they had done before.
Instead,
they ruled with arrogance and violence.
For this reason,
most of their allies could not bear their harshness and spoke to one another of
rebellion.
Some of them even disdained the lead counsel and active according to their own
wishes.
So did die.
Doors pick depicts a combined situation of which there are thoughts of the
affection and actual defections from Athens and blames this on the behavior of
the Athenians have a kind of a tyrannical sort.
Here's what's acidities says
now,
while there were other causes of revolts,
the principle ones where the failures in bringing in the tribute or their quota
of ships and in some cases refusal of military service for the Athenians exacted
the tribute strictly and gave a fence by applying coercive measures to any who
were accustomed or unwilling to bear the hardships of service.
And in some other respects to the Athenians were no longer equally agreeable as
leaders.
They would not take part in expeditions on terms of equality and they found it
easy to reduce those who had revolted.
Now here's where through acidities differs from Daya doors for all this.
The allies themselves were responsible for most of them.
Uh,
I'm sorry.
For most of them on account of their aversion to military service in order to
avoid being away from home got themselves rated in sums of money instead of
ships,
which they should pay in as their proportion of contribution.
And consequently,
the fleet of the Athenians was increased by the funds which they contributed
while they themselves,
whenever they revolted entered on the war without preparation and without
experience.
So the acidities certainly agrees with what dinosaur is says about the high
hand,
his manner in which the Athenians had become accustomed to behave and the
offense they gave to their allies.
But he points out that the allies had gotten themselves into that fixed because
many of them,
and this is an element died Dorris doesn't mention,
voluntarily said,
okay,
look,
we're not going to do this service anymore.
Instead of going supplying ships,
manning them,
doing the service ourselves,
we will pay the equivalent some into the league treasury.
And when they did so the Athenians took that money and used it to pay for
Athenian ships with Athenian rowers so that as the league forces grew smaller,
the Athenian navy grew bigger and so through acidity says it's,
they're all full.
In some cases it was not,
but certainly in many a case it was,
I think we should not think of Diet Doris and aunts acidities as contradicting
each other.
They really are complimentary.
They're both telling the same story but emphasizing a different perspective.
That one looked at it from the Athenian point of view,
one from the allied point of view.
But they certainly are telling it as it was.
And if we look ahead toward the end of the fifth century,
by the time we get to the Peloponnesian war of all the hundred and 50 or more
states that were members of the original Delian League,
only three still had a navy and real autonomy.
By the time the war broke out,
three great islands off the coast of Asia Minor,
uh,
less boss kiose and Samos where those states,
and sorry I should have said too,
because by four 44,
44 39 Samos lost its independence.
So there are only two states in that category.
Looking ahead,
that's what will happen.
That's what will be the end of the Delian League.
It will be the Athenian Empire in every respect.
Now,
while this development was taking place,
we need to take a look at what was happening back in the Greek world on the
mainland.
And,
uh,
chiefly,
I think we should focus on Athens for this.
Uh,
at this time,
there was right after the,
uh,
the Persian wars.
I said a few words about it before,
a rising competition for a place of standing in the Greek world.
That is to say before the Persian wars were over,
Sparta had been unquestionably the leader of the Greeks when challenged by an
outside force after the war.
The mystically as you recall,
uh,
and obviously with the Athenians at his back asserted at the very least,
equality with the Spartans and certainly independence of any position of
following the Spartans are any grant of leadership to the Spartans.
And as I think I mentioned last time,
the next 50 years or so are the story of the competition between these two great
powers within the Greek world for who would be the leader and there would be
many a clash in the course of that time in Athens.
The remarkable thing is if you look at the internal development of Athens,
think you would have said enforced 79,
uh,
some is,
is bound to rise to the top and become the dominant politician in Athens because
of his extraordinary play.
A role in bringing victory to the Greeks.
But a,
these things don't always happen that way.
I,
I think of course about the second world war where one might have thought the
same thing about Winston Churchill's future in English politics,
but no,
no.
Um,
no sooner was the war one and I think,
you know,
Churchill would have had to gain and was given enormous credit for bringing
about that victory.
Uh,
there was an election almost immediately after the war and Churchill was thrown
out and replaced by his opponents,
which tells you about,
uh,
the first rule of democratic politics.
The first important question that has to be put to all politicians,
which is what have you done for me lately?
Well,
he had done quite a lot lately.
So there's another question that you have to put is,
what are you going to do for me next?
I think that was really,
what was that Churchill's problem that was not some mystical,
he's problem to mystic.
Lee's ran into trouble because he,
he was a kind of a maverick in Athenian politics anyway,
although on,
at least on one side of his family,
he was a nobleman.
Unlike the typical Athenian leader,
uh,
he was not of the,
the real sort of center of the aristocracy.
There's some kind of a less than extraordinary,
uh,
nobility in part of his family and his personality.
People fantas his rivals found troubling because he was not a verse to a basking
in the glory that he had one.
Um,
but think back,
um,
in the 80s,
in the years between marathon and Salmas,
on the one hand,
it's a mystic.
Lee's had,
um,
enabled to convince the Athenians to do what they needed to do to survive,
to build that great fleets out of the silver mines that they had striking the
silver mines that they had been lucky enough to have.
But also he had managed,
if,
uh,
my reading of the facts is correct,
get to get rid of every one of his major political opponents by making use of
the device of ostracism.
If you look at the eighties,
you will see that just about every important Athenian political figure is
ostracized with the exception of the mystical lees who was left in great shape
while the other folks are gone.
And when the Persians come,
the ostracized men are recalled and play a role in the war.
And when the war is over,
it's obvious.
I think that they are both not happy with what's the mystical he's had achieved
against them and also worried about their prospects for the future with the
mystical,
he's being a bigger hero than he ever was.
So what I think we have begun to understand Athenian politics in the years after
the Persian war.
We must understand that there is some kind of a coalition,
formal or otherwise in which all the great leaders of the Athenian,
uh,
political world combined to keep some mystical.
He's down amazingly enough.
When we take a look at the early actions of the Delian League in which in every
case,
remember the commander of every expedition isn't Athenian.
It's never some mystical Lee's whom you would have imagined would have been
leading all these expeditions.
He just didn't have the political clout to get the assignment.
The man who did was a relatively young man by the name of on a nobleman.
He was the son of [inaudible],
the great hero at a marathon.
And he started out his political career with the problems his,
his,
uh,
his father had been condemned,
the at bay just before his death.
He had also left a very,
a great debt that came on,
had to repay.
But a Cayman established himself as a great figure in the Persian wars.
And a very soon afterwards,
we see him taking the lead in every campaign pretty much that the Delian league
launches.
And he is stunningly successful.
He's obviously a great commander on land and at sea.
He's in charge of the great victory at you Ramadan.
And so as Athens goes from greatness to greatness,
from success to success and glory to glory.
And from wealth to wealth,
uh,
Kimani becomes this extraordinarily popular with the masses.
And it's interesting because he was not the sort of a man who appealed to the
lower classes.
He was a nobleman himself and he never backed off that.
And as we shall see in a moment,
uh,
his,
prejudices about foreign relations were not the popular ones.
He was a great supporter of Sparta,
a great friend of Sparta who regularly spoke about the virtues of Sparta and the
spartan system and how Athens could learn something from Sparta.
How such a man could have been elected general year after year by the masses of
the Athenians is a question we need to approach.
Um,
but he,
the virtues that he had were,
uh,
to some considerable degree personal that is not only was I think first and
foremost was the enormous success he had and commanding the Athenian forces had
brought all the things I've mentioned and,
and wealth because the,
the league expeditions attacking various Persian territory's brought booty,
which was to some extent divided up among the armies that did the fighting so
that the Athenian soldiers and sailors actually made a profit out of these
conquests of Persian territory or raids on Persian territory naturally that
their commander was popular on that score.
But he had those personal skills that are successful in democratic politics.
He just,
people liked him.
He had,
I'm reminded of a,
the same political phenomenon in America.
In the case of Eisenhower,
Eisenhower of course had first become the popular politician because of his
victory in the Second World War.
He was in command of the European theater and got all the credit or a lot of
credit for the victory.
But he had these qualities that made people like him,
of which,
you know,
trivial things can be very important.
In Eisenhower's case,
they liked his smile.
People talked about it all the time.
Uh,
and uh,
it turned out he was unbeatable in politics.
And it was a little bit like that in the case of on,
uh,
even though again,
Eisenhower was not on the,
on the sort of the populous side of these things.
He was after all a Republican,
uh,
and he turned out he was pretty orthodox in that sense.
Well,
it came on,
held to a very conservative position,
as I will tell you about in just a moment.
So,
uh,
but the fact is he becomes the dominant politician and Athens,
if you think of him rising to the top as early as four 79 when the war is over.
And then we know that his period of,
of,
uh,
political success in Athens ends in the year for 62,
that's a 17 years stretch,
which is at a very,
very long time for a politician to continue to be the leading figure in this
state,
in Athens,
remembering Athenian general.
And it turns out that the development of the Athenian democracy was that it was
the generals who came to be the leading figures politically in the state.
And the generals have to be elected every year.
So think about how consistently you have to be popular with the masses in order
to achieve the leadership that came on did.
Um,
his pro spartan foreign policy,
I think is a very critical part of the tail.
And I think things would have been very,
very different if the mystic Lee's had been the dominant politician because it
was clear that from what he'd already done and what he will do later,
that he was anti Spartan and urging a Athenian independence from Sparta and,
and really hostility between the two sides.
Uh,
came on to the contrary.
He was the official representative of Sparta in Athens.
Uh,
he had long family associations with them.
He went around and explaining,
as I said,
uh,
the virtues of the Spartans and how good it would be for Athens to emulate some
of them.
But more important than that.
He was always in favor of a policy that had Athens and Sparta allies together
equals as they had been in his mind,
uh,
in the,
great Persian war,
when a fundamentally the Spartan said,
led the great one and led in one the great victory or on land that placea the
Athenians had lead and won the victory at Salomon [inaudible] at sea and the two
states collaborated,
cooperated and in that's how af has,
that's how the Greeks were freed from the Persian menace.
And that's how Greece would prosper and be safe in the future.
And it worked some part of the fact that the Spartans did not object to the
developments in the gene and across the Aegean in which Athens moved from being
merely the leader of a coalition to becoming an imperial power stronger every
day.
The Spartans didn't do a thing about it in those early years.
Why not?
I think a major reason was because Keeman was the dominant figure in Athens.
They trusted came on.
They knew that so long as he was in that position,
he would not be a menace to Sparta.
And that they could indeed live side by side in this way.
It was a stretch of time,
15,
17,
something like that,
years which was peaceful.
Uh,
and as I say,
probably would not have been without the phenomenon of the internal developments
in Athens itself
came on also.
And his,
his control of Athenian Affairs by virtue of his personal standing and his
persuasive abilities are also surprising.
Marathon was a victory for hoplites.
It was the farmers,
the middling group and those above them that won that battle.
But Salomon us was a victory for the poor.
Inactives of course,
that vast fleet was road by poor Athenians and now they had the glory for the,
for the victory.
And they,
and every of course after the work,
when the fleet became the basis of Athenian strength and glory,
it was the common man who was and the poorest of the Athenians who was involved
in achieving that,
uh,
desirable status.
So you would have thought,
and if the mystical he's had been in control,
I'm sure you would have been right,
that there would be a movement towards greater democratization of the state.
Remember where we are before the wars begin is Cli Stenek democracy,
which is pretty much a hoplite democracy and which excludes the poor from many
of the activities of the state came on,
ran against that.
He basically,
he never tried to unravel Athenian democracy is not an enemy of Athenian
democracy.
He was in favor of keeping it the way it was and in some ways actually rolling
back some degree of democracy.
The way it was somewhat rolled back was that,
and not by any legal position or illegal action,
but rather by sort of the way events went forward.
Aristotle in the Constitution of the Athenians describes the stretch of time,
uh,
that I'm talking about by four 79,
four 62 as the period of the Areola gyrates constitution.
What that means is the old areas to credit council consisting of former top
magistrates gained unofficial informal but very real power.
Scholars have had a hard time understanding exactly what it was.
That was the nature of that power.
But it looks as though a couple of elements with certainly there and there were
very critical.
That is the area out because it was said,
sort of regained the,
the oversight of magistrates.
They were,
uh,
as in the,
in the Arab Socratic past,
in the position of being able to have criticized magistrates and to take action
against them if they acted in a way that the area abicus did not approve.
And it also seems very plausible that even though they're continued to be a
council of 500,
which was continuing to function as it had ever since the Cli Senate
constitution had established it.
The fact is that more and more the area bigass was taking decisions about
foreign policy,
uh,
was putting to the assembly when they desired motions.
They were usurping some of the powers of the 500.
They would not doing this as I keep saying by no chain,
by any change of the law,
they were doing it because they thought they could.
And the people accepted it.
One reason for it,
according to Aristotle,
is that they had played a particularly heroic role in the Persian wars at the
moment when the Persians invaded Attica and the Athenians were forced to flee
their homes.
And to go to sal amiss and to the Peloponnesus to escape for that moment.
Now the poor had no wherewithal to keep themselves alive when they went into
exile in this way.
And so the area opera giants use their own money to keep the poor alive and in
good condition during that period of time.
They volunteer that action and that generosity and patriotism and goodwill
allowed the development of this area [inaudible] constitution in the years that
came.
And that's what came on,
I think really had in mind.
He wanted to have this sort of dual policy of conservative,
moderate democracy conservative in that it did not take any recognition of the
changing circumstances that would have given the poor a better claim to
political power and also,
um,
conservative in the sense that it was not going to challenge the Doula did the
dualism of Greek international relations as it had emerged from the Persian war.
And that's the policy that Athens followed with tremendous success,
um,
during the late career of Keeman while he was at the head of affairs.
Remember,
I keep saying he's at the head of affairs and he's running things,
but remember he's just one of 10 generals who is elected every year.
So all of his,
his info,
it's,
I,
yeah,
I was going to say is power,
but it's be better to speak of his influence because it's all unofficial.
He is able to have these things happen because people do what he urges them to
do when they don't need to.
There's no compulsion necessary.
He is the one who sets the tone and they follow him.
Uh,
centuries later when Augustus becomes the boss of the Roman world,
um,
his own statement of the situation put the way he wanted people to think about
it was that he was foremost not in power protest us is the Latin word,
but rather in terms of his,
his influence,
uh,
he wanted to say,
it was not a tyranny.
It was not a monarchy.
It was a republic,
as it had always been an eye Augustus as the leading citizen in the eyes of my
fellow Romans am able to persuade them,
uh,
to do these things,
not because they have to be because they want to.
Well,
that was his story and it wasn't true because he had a great big army at his
back.
And if you wanted to move him out of anything,
you would just have to get yourself killed.
This was not the situation with chemo.
He came on,
could have made that speech and it would have been true.
So all that cruises along until we get to the,
uh,
fasion rebellion came on,
is in charge of that expedition.
And,
uh,
it proves to be a much tougher problem than any that he has had to face before
the war extends for a long time.
There's no success there has,
there's expense and no pay off.
And of course,
there's some question as to the legitimacy and decency of what is going on here.
So I'm the enemies of Pericles.
I'm sorry,
of Kmart.
In a moment I'll tell you about them.
Take advantage of the discontent.
That decision rebellion is causing to launch an attack on,
came on politically for the first time in anybody's memory.
The opponents,
the these,
uh,
enemies of chemo on are in the first instance,
a man calledF elts.
And very soon it becomes clear that he has as a kind of a lieutenant,
uh,
a younger man who was a important but subordinate to Effie out these,
that young man is Peric Lee's the son of sense.
Ipus censorship is the great Persian war hero.
We are told it's very hard to disentangle the effects from the stories here,
but,
uh,
fel elts was opposed to a,
have been associated with some mystical lees and that's very plausible because
certainly fel these deserves to be thought of as a democratic leader with the
underlining of the Democrat.
He is clearly attempting to make a change in the constitution and de facto at
the very least,
uh,
which would allow the navel crowd,
the poor people of Athens who row in the fleets to have more political power and
opportunity.
And he is also very strongly anti spartan so that he is opposed to both halves
of the key Monique one approach to things and he works at trying to undermine
and to defeat came on.
We had no luck at toll until say sauce and then they bring charges against,
came on.
You know,
he hadn't done anything wrong.
What we had done was not win the war very quickly,
but,
uh,
you know,
you make up charges in the world of politics.
You,
you've heard of that.
And once or twice and a e s B,
they said,
well,
the reason,
uh,
he hadn't won the war so quickly was because he had been bribe by the king of
Macedonia,
which is right behind the territory.
We're talking about,
uh,
not to conquer Macedonia.
Well,
guess what?
He wasn't under orders to conquer Macedonia.
He had no plan to conquer.
Macedonia,
didn't need to be bribed,
not to,
uh,
conquered Macedonia on top of which it was pretty,
pretty hard to bribe Keeman because although he had started out poor from his
father's death,
he was now an enormously rich guy because of the booty which he had legitimately
acquired in his role as commander of those expeditions.
Everybody knew who he was.
He was incredibly rich and he was very generous with his riches and gave it away
in all sorts of ways.
Eh,
you know,
if you want to say that,
uh,
Rockefeller is a no good low down polecat that's fine,
but if you want to say he's being bribed with money,
all you're going to do is get laughter at is something like that.
And in a sense and in some way that is the situation with Kimani.
Um,
so,
um,
uh,
the uh,
trial is not nonetheless launched against Chemo on the,
uh,
the complainants is paraclese this young up and coming democratic politician who
makes the case against Chemo on,
he loses,
of course he loses it,
came on,
has not lost his support.
And the case is absurd.
It's just a sign that for the first time there's some kind of serious political
opposition and who is involved in it.
Even before that trial fel ds had tried another technique by attacking the area
opera Gus through a tax on particular area,
opera giants.
If you don't have any success in the general political arena,
one device that is as old as the hills and as new as yesterday is,
you tried to discredit individuals in the regime that you're trying to unseat.
And so various charges were brought against particular area.
The opera giants,
they might've had merit,
they might not.
The goal was to discredit the area.
[inaudible] as a whole,
again,
did not succeed in the years that I am talking about.
These are just the signs of what we're talking about,
which takes us to the years just after the,
uh,
putting down of the fasion rebellion is enormous argument.
Scholars that never will go away about just what is the date of the terrible
earthquake that hit the Peloponnesus in whatever time.
The most common,
uh,
opinion is that it was around four 64 and that's,
that appeals to me too.
And the earthquake was so serious as to disrupt life in Sparta and in Spartan
territory in general,
and thereby to encourage a great hell out rebellion so that the ladder,
even after the earthquake was over,
was what occupied and terrified the Spartans.
And it was serious enough that they sent out to their allies.
And I'm not now talking merely about their allies in the Peloponnesian League,
in their allies who had joined them in the Greek league against Persia,
which was still on the books and asking them to send help against the hell
[inaudible].
And a number of them did.
And it's indicative of what the relationship between Athens and Sparta was that
they also asked for help in Athens to athletes.
There was a great debate in the Athenian Assembly as to what answer to give the
Spartans in their request for help.
And,
um,
came on of course,
made the case for doing so.
And in fact,
he proposed that the Athenians sent a very large force as these things go in the
Greek world of 4,000 hoplites.
That's a very big army.
The Athenians very rarely send an army of that size outside of Athens,
uh,
into the Peloponnesus to help the Spartans against the hell odds.
Uh,
he made the case that,
uh,
Athens should not,
abandoned.
It's a former ally.
He,
uh,
he spoken panhellenic terms using uh,
a nice folk expression.
He said,
uh,
Greece should not,
allow,
uh,
this kind of a split.
Athens should not lose its yoke fellow.
And the image was a team of oxen drawing a plow.
Athens and Sparta being that team.
And so long as they're in the same yoke and doing the thing,
all will be well,
Greece will be safe.
They will be no internal strife.
There'll be no war.
That's what we ought to do.
Fel these spoke bitterly against that and,
uh,
spoken terms of this,
this story is all told in Plutarch's life of Cayman.
You want to have a look at that.
Uh,
he seems to have evidence about what was said of this debate in the assembly.
And if elts is boast to have said something like,
the,
the arrogance of Sparta must be trampled underfoot.
Uh,
and he lost the argument,
came on once again,
won the argument.
Athens sends a force of these 4,000 hoplites down into the Peloponnesus.
They were called on,
especially Spartans wanted them because the hell out said runaway to mount if
foamy in Miss Enia,
uh,
which was a four to five place on a mountain,
very hard to,
uh,
attack.
The Spartans had failed in their efforts to besiege or just storm the position
there.
And the Athenians had a reputation now of being very good at siege warfare,
which they had gained at the end of the Persian wars.
You remember,
uh,
[inaudible] said,
a besieged and taken assessed us in a very effective way.
Well,
the Athenians went and had a shot at it and fail,
at which point the Spartans were a little bit less keen on having them there.
And then very soon after that,
the Athenians went to the,
I'm sorry,
the Spartans went to the Athenians and said,
thank you very much for your contribution.
Uh,
we have no further need of your services.
Have a nice trip home.
Instead of being very grateful and happy that they didn't have to fight anymore,
the Athenians were insulted.
None of the other allies was asked to leave.
None of the others were gone.
The Athenians are clearly had been sent away,
not for out of friendly reasons.
Uh,
and Susan that he's tells us what was on the mind,
that the Spartans who made these decisions,
they had developed a fear of the Athenian soldiers who were in the Peloponnesus.
They,
you know,
do you know,
typically you don't Spartans don't get to see or know anybody else.
The only time they ever get to see foreigners is with that and be fighting side
by side briefly.
But now you can imagine the scene where these ordinary,
everyday Athenians having been born and raised in a democracy where there is
absolute freedom and freedom of speech,
uh,
and were there a style of life is not bad for a Greek by Greek standards.
And you can imagine these,
uh,
inviting these Athenian soldiers in for a,
for a meal and feeding them a spartan meal,
black soup.
And the Athenians think
that this is what you get the hell out,
right?
You're not going to eat that stuff,
You want us to eat that stuff?
I wouldn't feed it to a pig.
I'm inventing the conversation.
But you've got the general idea.
And the Spence couldn't have enjoyed that very much.
And then,
uh,
as they looked around and fence,
so what kind of estate this was in,
which there were all these enslaved people.
He'd vast numbers,
enslaved people,
not the kind of slaves they knew about the ones who,
who,
where you had a,
like a handyman over assisted you on the farm,
the vast numbers of them doing all the work while the Spartans didn't do any.
Uh,
and then they saw that the business was run by a small group of people at the
average spartan soldier had nothing to say about what was going on.
Uh,
and then being Athenians,
they no doubt,
said something about that.
And so acidity says to Spartans became fearful that they would in fact help the
hell odds in a rebellion against the Spartans.
And that in general,
he feared the Spartans feared there revolutionaries spirit.
And it was on that ground that they sent them away.
In any case,
it was no doubt in the minds of the Athenians,
they had been sent away,
not in an honorable way in which friends treat friends,
but they had been dismissed.
And when they came home,
they were furious that they had gone in the first place,
angry with Cayman for sending them.
And four of course,
is pro sport and position in general.
And in the spring of four 62,
four 61 is it maybe,
I think it's forced 61 they ostracized Kimani and off he went.
That was the sort of the deadly stroke in what was now fairly,
could fairly be called a political revolution in Athens.
It was not brought about by force.
It was brought about in a constitutional way,
but it nonetheless put an end to a whole stretch of time in which the state was
run in a certain way and brought about new kinds of,
uh,
an,
new,
uh,
new development,
let us say,
a development towards a fuller democracy,
but it's immediate consequences where a complete breach with Sparta,
the Athenians renounced their old alliance made in the Hellenic League.
And for 81,
uh,
that was over,
they turned around and made alliances with Argos Sparta's bitter Peloponnesian
enemies.
They made an alliance with the people in the north,
the first aliens who were famous for their cavalry.
And the implication of that being that the Athenians had warlike intentions
against the Spartans signing up,
first of all,
with their most famous local enemy and then signing up for the,
uh,
opportunity to have a,
a cavalry to use as well.
And indeed,
as we will see,
it did leave very soon to a war between Athens and Sparta.
And there are the two sets of allies in what modern historians call the first
Peloponnesian war.
But before we get to that,
I think we want to attend to the great changes in Athens internally that were
brought about by this great revolution.
I think first thing we need to do is to dispose of flts,
which is what his enemies did almost immediately this he was murdered.
Somebody came and stuck a knife in him.
Uh,
it's very interesting.
This is the only political assassination that we know of in the entire history
of the Athenian democracy.
And when you think of how few worthy methods for protecting anybody in the
Athenian state,
it really is a remarkable thing is sometimes I think when you look back at the
history of the United States and the number of presidents who have either been
killed or shot at,
uh,
attempts made to kill them,
it's quite extraordinary that the Athenians,
this is the only case we know,
nobody knows,
knows to this day who committed it.
There were various rumors of which
one is obviously inspired by political considerations and hard to believe,
uh,
claims that [inaudible] killed them in order to clear the way for his own
leadership of the Democratic faction.
I don't think we need to take that seriously,
but that was one of the charges.
More likely it was the murder was brought about by disgruntled chemoed,
Ian's disgruntled conservatives,
disgruntled aristocrats,
people who were very angry at the turn of events that had changed everything in
Athens.
But if we look at the situation in Athens in four 60,
one 40,
60,
and so on,
uh,
we are seeing a movement towards a democratic,
I don't want to say revolution,
I suppose,
but a rapid movement to make the state,
the city of Athens more democratic than it ever had been.
And,
uh,
I'd like to turn next to the story of what that
full blown Athenian democracy was like and how it worked.
Let me just remind you that in the decade before 500,
if we go back to the client centric world,
the Greeks who lived in the city state called Athens,
established a world's first democratic constitution.
But this new kind of government was carried to it's classical stage by the
reforms of [inaudible] a half a century in these years between 40 60 and four 50
is really when most of the action took place.
And it was in the Athens shaped by Perricone.
Is that the greatest achievements of the Greek world to place?
We should remember that the rest of the world continued to be characterized by
monarchical rigidly hierarchical command societies while in democracy,
while in Athens,
democracy was carried as far as it would go before modern times.
Perhaps if you look at it in a certain way further than any other place and
time.
And I,
I'm going to start asking you to,
to,
uh,
be aware of your prejudices and to hold them lightly so that you can have the
most full understanding of things that may have the same names.
But really we're very different from things that we are accustomed to.
For one thing,
it's worth pointing out right away was Athenian democracy.
The act,
the access to the political process was limited in Athens to adult males of
native parentage
Athenian citizen.
His ship granted full and active participation in every decision of the state
without regard to the wealth or the class of the citizen.
And the four fifties under [inaudible] leadership,
the Athenian Assembly passed a series of laws that went far towards establishing
a constitution that was as thoroughly democratic as the world has ever seen.
It gave direct and ultimate power to the citizens in the assembly and in the
popular law courts where the people made all decisions by a simple majority vote
and it provided for the selection of most public offices by allotment for the
direct election of a very special few and for short terms of office and close
control over all po public officials.
We need to have a clear understanding of the kind of regime paraclese reforms
produced for.
I don't think it's easy for citizens of what are called democracies in the 20th
century,
21st century to comprehend the character of the democracy of ancient Athens and
the role that it played in the life of its citizens.
To a degree that's hard for us to grasp.
Politics was primary in the ancient Greek city and the form of the constitution
was and expected to shape the character of its citizens,
the art,
the literature,
the philosophy,
and all the great achievements of [inaudible] Athens cannot be fully understood
apart from their political and constitutional context into democracy established
by Christ in these and then extended by paraclese later.
I think the place to start with a description of the Athenian democracy is with
some attempt at a definition of the term developments in the modern world make
that really hard for the word has become debased and is almost meaningless.
Few modern states will admit to being anything but democratic.
That is confusing enough,
but there are further complications.
Many people today would insist that to qualify as a democracy,
a state must offer a full constitutional and political protections and
opportunities to all who have legal permanent residents within its borders and
who desire citizenship.
But the Athenians limited the right to vote,
to hold office,
to serve on juries,
to adult males who were citizens,
slaves,
resident aliens,
women and male citizens under the age of 20 were denied.
All these privileges,
modern critics of ancient Athens question the democratic character of the Para
Cleon regime because of the presence of slavery and the exclusion of women from
political life in excluding such groups,
the Athenians were like every other society since the invention of civilization,
about 3000 BC until just recently.
So it's really not too interesting or amazing to point out this a shortcoming
from our point of view,
what sets the Athenians apart on not these exclusions,
but the unusually large degree of inclusion,
as well as the extraordinarily significant and rewarding participation of those
who were included.
It's useful to remember that what has been called the Jacksonian democracy in
the United States coexisted with slavery in the its fullest moments that women
were everywhere denied the right to vote until the 20th century and that we
continue to limit political participation to those of a specified age
to deny the title of democracy to Perricone in Athens because of those excluded
would be to employ a parochial and anachronistic set of criteria that produce
paradoxical results.
Certainly no contemporary Greek doubted that Athens was a democracy.
The only argument was whether a democracy was good or bad,
which is it almost an unthinkable question to put in our own time
to look at it from the other end.
The Athenians would have been astonished at the claim of modern states to that
title,
even such states as the United States and Great Britain.
For to them,
an essential feature of democracy was the direct and full sovereignty of the
majority of citizens,
government by elected representatives,
checks and balances,
separation of powers appointment,
two important offices,
unelected bureaucracies,
judicial life,
tenure terms for elective office have more than one year.
All of these would have seemed clear and deadly enemies of what reasonable
people might understand by democracy.
So these differences between ancient and modern ideas require a brief
examination of how the Athenian Democracy worked if we are to shed our
prejudices and grasped the character of a form of government that is as rare as
any in the history of the world.
And that probably never existed in anything like the same form after the end of,
uh,
Athenian autonomy.
So I like to use a helpful if anachronistic advice by considering the three
familiar branches into which we divide government,
legislative,
executive,
and judiciary.
At the heart of what we would call the legislative branch of the Athenian
Democracy was the assembly there were,
it was a clay sia.
It was open to all the adult male citizens of Athens during [inaudible]
lifetime.
These may have been 40,000,
possibly as many as 50,000 men.
And now most Athenians lived many miles from the city,
few owned horses.
So attendance required a very long walk to town.
So as a result,
the number of taking part normally was well short of that,
it was probably from five to 6,000 people.
One reason for saying that is that there was a quorum for some actions that you
had to have at least 6,000 votes.
On the one hand that tells us,
I think that there were,
uh,
probably more than that,
who attended the assembly.
You wouldn't make a core and being everybody,
whoever attended the place.
But on the other hand,
it suggests that there were many assemblies with fewer than 6,000 votes.
The meetings took place outside on a hill called the panics,
not far from the Acropolis and overlooking the Agora citizens sat on the earth
of this sharply sloping hill,
and the speakers stood on a low platform.
It was not easy for them to make themselves heard.
You can imagine it's an outdoor place.
They don't have microphones.
The great fourth century orators are set to have practice.
Well Demosthenes,
he's the greatest of them,
is said to have practiced speaking at the seashore over the crashing surf to
make his voice strong enough to be heard on the [inaudible].
A good loud voice was really a terrific asset for an Athenian politician.
We've got some idea of the opening of these meetings from a comic version that
is given to us in Aristophanes comedy at Carney ens performed in the year for 25
the speaker is a typical Aristo fannick comic hero and old fashion farmer from
the backwoods who complains about the war.
War is now about six years old because it keeps him in Athens,
away from his farm in the country.
I quote now from the Irish Stefanik passage,
it is the day of an assembly.
He says he's a,
by the way,
he's sitting there all by himself on the panics.
Nobody has come yet and there he is complaining.
It is that Dave and assembly and already morning,
but the Pernix is deserted.
They are chattering in the Agora dodging the rope dripping with red dye.
That's a reference to the fact that the Athenians are always slow to come from
the marketplace,
the Agora,
the city center,
and make it up the hill to the [inaudible] because they were so busy talking
that they just wouldn't get going.
So the,
the,
uh,
officials had some guy's carrying a rope dipped in red dye.
They circled the Agora and they kept closing the circle until uh,
everybody was out.
You would be running away from them in the first place because you wouldn't want
to get your coat full of red dye.
And so that's,
that's what he's referring to.
You said even the presidents of the assembly have not arrived.
They will be late.
And when they finally come,
they will push and fight each other for a seat in the front row,
streaming down all together.
You can't imagine how,
but they will say nothing about making peace.
Oh my Athens.
I am always the first to make the return voyage to the assembly and take my
seat.
And since I am alone,
I groan.
I yawn,
I stretch my legs,
I fart.
I don't know what to do.
I write,
I pull out my loose hairs,
I add up my accounts,
looking off at my fields,
longing for peace,
hating the town,
sick for my village home,
which never said by my charcoal,
my vinegar,
my oil,
the word by his unknown there where everything is free.
And so I have come here fully prepared to shout,
to interrupt,
to abuse the speakers if they talk about anything but peace.
But here come these noon time presidents,
didn't I tell you,
didn't I predict they would?
How they would come?
Everyone.
Jocelyn up to the front seat.
Next,
the herald of the assembly says move up,
move up within the consecrated area.
And then he recites the formula that regularly begins debate in the assembly.
He simply says who wishes to speak at which somebody raises a hand.
Then the game gets started.
Okay,
that's the comic version.
But the real meetings on the picnics were rarely comic.
They dealt with serious questions.
You Assembly had four fixed meetings,
uh,
in each of the 10 periods into which the official year was divided and also
special.
Additional meetings were cold flow when necessary.
Topics included the approval or disapproval of treaties,
making declarations of war,
assigning generals to campaigns,
deciding what forces and resources they should command,
confirming officials or removing them from office,
deciding whether or not to hold an ostracism.
Questions concerning religion,
questions of inheritance,
in fact,
anything else that anybody wanted to bring up in the assembly.
It's especially amazing for a citizen of a modern representative democracy to
read of these great town meetings dealing directly with questions of foreign
policy that could mean life or death for those present at the debate and for
their entire city.
To get some idea of the distance between ancient and modern democracy,
we need only to consider how an emergency say the seizure of an American embassy
would be dealt with today in the United States.
It would probably have arrived first as secret information at some bureau of the
government's vast and complex complex intelligence service.
Although it could also just show up on CNN for the before the government knows,
but it would be treated as highly confidential and revealed only to a few people
in the White House.
The state and defense departments
policy would be discussed in a small close group and the decision made by one
man,
ultimately the president of the United States.
And if there were no leaks,
I big if people would hear if it only when the die had been cast and model for
this,
those of my vintage where was the Cuban missile crisis,
which was kept as a great secret.
In those days,
the press actually would keep secrets in behalf of the national security.
He imagines such an old fashioned approach.
Uh,
but uh,
and then they had been kicking it around for a week when the president got on
television and told us what the menace was and what he was doing about it.
It was too late to have any discussion or argument about it.
But that's the way it works in our system.
Questions of war and peace rose more than once in perfectly in Athens.
And each time the popular assembly had a full debate and made the decision by
raising their hands in a vote determined by a simple majority.
I don't think there's any stronger evidence of the full and final sovereignty of
the Athenian people on the most important questions.
Then that fact that that is the way they made those decisions and assembly of
thousands of course could not do its business without help.
For that,
it relied on the council of 500 chosen by lot from all Athenian citizens.
Although it performed many public functions that the larger body could not
handle efficiently.
It's main responsibility was to prepare legislation for consideration by the
people in this respect.
As in all others,
the council was the servant of the assembly.
The assembly could vote down a bill drafted by the council.
They could change it on the floor,
they could send it back,
for instance,
with instructions for re drafting or they could replace it with an entirely
different bill.
Full sovereignty and the real exercise of Public Authority rested directly with
the assembly.
Almost no constitutional barrier prevented.
A majority of the citizens assembled on the picnics on a particular day from
doing anything they wanted to do.
Turning to the executive and what we would call the executive.
These distinctions did not exist for the Athenians.
They didn't make these divisions but to help us understand that I'm using these
terms but we might call.
The executive was severely limited in extent in discretion and power and the
distinction between legislative and judicial authority was far less clear than
in our own society to begin with.
There was no precedent,
no prime minister,
no cabinet.
There was not any elected official for the management of the state in general
for formulating or proposing a general policy.
Nothing that Americans would call an administration or that the British would
call a government.
The chief elected officials were 10 generals voted for a one year term as their
title indicated.
They were basically military officials who commanded the army and the navy.
They could be reelected without limit and extraordinary men like Kimani and
Paraclese were elected almost every year,
but they were very exceptional.
The political power,
such men exercise was limited to their personal ability to persuade their fellow
citizens in the assembly to follow their advice.
They had no special political or civil authority and accept on military and
naval campaigns.
They couldn't give orders to anybody.
Even in military matters.
The powers of the generals were severely limited.
Leaders of expeditions was selected by vote of the full Athenian Assembly,
which also determined the size of the force and what goals it should pursue.
Before the generals took office,
they were subjected to a scrutiny of their qualifications by the council of 500
after completing their year of service,
their performance on the job and especially their financial accounts,
we're subject to audit in a special process called a youth tuna.
No.
Was this the only control by the people over the few officials chosen by
election 10 times a year,
the popular assembly voted to determine whether the generals conduct of military
affairs appears satisfactory and if the people vote against someone's
confirmation in office,
he is tried in a law court.
If he is found guilty,
they assess his punishment or fine.
If he is acquitted,
he resumed his office.
Since elected office conferred prestige,
elected officials were carefully confirmed a control rather less.
They should undermine the rule of the people.
That's what's behind all of this.
Careful check on the generals.
Even with these severe controls,
the Athenians fulfilled only a few public officer's by election choosing their
military officials there,
naval architects and only some of their treasurers as well as the superintendent
of the city water supply in that manner.
All other officials and there were a good number of them were chosen by lot
allotment,
was the characteristic device by which the Athenians chose their officials in
accordance with the dominant democratic principle,
which was equality,
which held that any citizen who was capable of performing civil responsibilities
well enough and its corollary,
that feared allowing executive or administrative power to fall into the hands of
a few men,
even those who were experienced or had special abilities for these reasons,
the Athenians fill,
uh,
fill the bulk of their offices by lot and limited tenure to one,
term per man in each office except for the council of 500,
where a man could serve twice in the course of his life.
Generals,
however,
it could be reelected forever because it was so obvious that issues of skill and
ability where literally vital in that job.
And so that was the one real exception to being limited to a very short term,
to a degree that is amazing to the modern mind.
The Athenians kept the management of their public life in the hands of ordinary
citizens,
away from professors,
professionals,
experts,
bureaucrats,
and politicians.
I'll pick up the rest of the story next time.